Damn, that hurts!
I dunno what you've heard,
but I don’t ambush so easy.
Shit, that was my
ball-scratchin’ hand.
I oughta kill you now for that image.
- Don't!
- Please wait!
Don’t shoot.
Them boys meant no harm!
No? Then how about you?
Come on, would you hurt
a defenseless old woman?
Please let it go.
I'm Mama Hitch. These are
my boys, Joe-Bob and Bob-Bob.
They’re sweet kids. Ain't no way
they'd commit theft or murder.
I dunno...
Pleased to meet you, Mother Hitch!
I’m Sam,
Special Associate Model from Botica.
These are my friends
Philly and Casey!
Seriously? This again?
She's programmed to be friendly.
Why not watch and learn?
Pleased to meet you, Sam. Me and my
kin have been stranded here a spell.
The boys thought you were
marauders coming for a raid.
Can’t be too careful
‘round these parts.
You guys are fishy.